nun hat sie den wahlkampf noch
regelrecht versendet robert habeck wird
dagegen für seine auftritte gefeiert und
kreierte berbalk inzwischen auch
kritisiert werbung inzwischen natürlich
auch ganz offen und da haben wir schnell
mal rein
grünen annalena baerbock vor den neuen
buch passagen abgeschrieben zu haben die
grünen reagieren die grünen weisen die
plagiatsvorwürfe gegen kanzler
kandidaten entschieden zurück das ganze
sei eine rufmord versuchen die woche und
für die wochen danach war sicherlich
der isaf kritisiert öffentlich die
kanzlerkandidatin das ist schon ein
großes großer vorgang innerhalb eines
wahlkampfs und es zeigt was aus meiner
sicht zeigt es mehrere dinge erstens
zeigt dass robert habeck noch immer hat
das ja sozusagen nicht berücksichtigt
worden ist bei den grünen als
kanzlerkandidat viele sagen ja wäre der
bessere kandidat gewesen er ist hält
selber hält sich glaube ich auch für den
besseren kandidaten
und um das nicht so arrogant erscheinen
zu lassen er wäre der bessere kandidat
gewesen das sehe ich genauso er ist
sozusagen klüger erhält die besseren
reden er hat die grünen auf den neuen
höchststand gebracht und annalena
baerbock hat das ja versemmelt ist das
richtige wort wir müssen uns das ja noch
mal vor augen führen die grünen waren
bei 20 prozent estland hat darüber
diskutiert wir in diesem studio haben
darüber diskutiert das politische berlin
darüber diskutiert ob die grünen
womöglich sogar stärkste partei werden
können bei der wahl also vor spd und cdu
liegen können dann begann annalena
baerbock mit dem wahlkampf und all den
pannen und jetzt stehen sie vor bei 15
prozent also von 20 auf 15 ist quasi die
baerbock kurve das wird dazu führen dass
sie immer noch als eine art
gefeierte siegerin für den wahlabend
wahrscheinlich am sonntag rumlaufen wird
aber sie ist die stimmen für nicht darin
und einer war immer da und hätte es
besser gekonnt und der plant aus meiner
sicht etwas er ist sozusagen maximal
bestärkt er hat sich loyal verhalten
auch das empfindet man ja nicht direkt
als illoyalität sondern nur als das
aussprechen von einer wirklichkeit aber
hätte er jetzt nicht vier tage vor der
wahl einfach mal die klappe gehalten gut
also vielleicht steckt ein kleiner
markus markus söder in eben ja dass er
und ist für mich ist das total recht das
wäre politisch angezeigt und es zeigt
dass etwas in etwas in ihm und ich
glaube dass da auch mehr dahinter steckt
nach der wahl wenn diese verlogene
wahlabend also wir sind die große sieger
die grünen 15 prozent oder 13 oder 16
wir haben gewonnen wird sich an dem
abend außer uns keiner daran erinnern
dass x 20 watt und dass das eigentliche
misserfolg ist das würde noch
wegschnappen aber für die zeit danach
wird er klar machen ich bin die nummer
eins bei den grünen und ich glaube dass
das sogar schon auswirkungen haben kann
auf die regierungsbildung denn es ist ja
kein zwang das annalena baerbock in
einer jamaika-koalition oder in einer
ampel die außenministerin wird das ist
keine keine selbstgänger vielleicht wird
es auch robert habeck das übrigens noch
interessant ich glaube dass viele leute
die jetzt sozusagen wählen sich einmal
auch klar machen müssen in den beiden
dreier bündnissen in denen die jetzt in
rede stehen jamaika und ampel ist
annalena baerbock die außenministerin
von deutschland da muss man sich auch
mal die frage stellt wie man das
eigentlich und er robert habeck will es
glaube ich nicht sondern er will glaube
ich und dafür würde vieles dafür
sprechen außer dann haben wir ein
kanzler und einen außenminister
und das spricht dann wieder für annalena
baerbock also die interessante
deformation der quote die schwächere
muss es machen weil sie eine frau ist
ich bin hundert prozent sicher dass
robert habe den ersten zugriff haben
wird der kann sich auf jeden fall das
ministerium das er haben will dass die
grünen bekommen können auf jeden fall
aussuchen ich bin mir nicht mal sicher
ob anna lena berber behaupten
ministerium bekommt und die
völkerrechtler und wenn das ist ja das
außenministerium vielleicht schon sie
erwähnt ja immer dass die
völkerrechtlerin ist man weiß aber nicht
genau warum sie völkerrechtlerin ist und
was sie als völkerrechtlerin bisher
geleistet hat aber das ist ja schon ihr
hallo ich bin eure aussenministerin
sprecher aber ja habig ist der neue alte
starke mann der grünen wo vielleicht ist
es in für ihn im nachhinein sogar
optimal gelaufen denn ob er kanzler
geworden wäre steht auch noch infrage
aber jetzt wird er auf jeden fall einer
der stärksten minister werden
[Musik]